ما زالت قضيه انهيار اسهم مجموعه اذان
الهنديه تثير تفاعلا في اوساط المستثمرين
بالعالم المجموعه التي يملكها الملياردير
غوتام اداني خسرت اكثر من 107 مليارات
دولار من قيمتها السوقيه منذ اصدار الشركه
هندربرغ الامريكيه تقريرا الاسبوع الماضي
اتهمت فيه مجموعه اذاانب التلاعب بالسوق
والاحتيال المحاسبي ما ادى الى عمليات بيع
مكثفه لاسهمها وقد نفت المجموعه تلك
المزاعم وتفاقمت خسائر اذاني بعد ان الغت
المجموعه بيع اسهم بقيمه مليارين ونصف
المليار دولار من خلال طرح ثانويا
بالبورصه
اني
وعلى اثر هذه الاخبار انخفضت الثروه
الشخصيه لصاحب المجموعه ما ادى الى خسارته
لقب اغنى رجلان في اسيا وفقد غوتام اداني
ما يقرب من 75 مليار دولار منذ وصول ثروته
للذروه عندما بلغت 145 مليار دولار في
العام الماضي وادت للخسائر الى هبوط رجل
الاعمال الهندي الى المركز الخامس عشر في
قائمه فوربس لاغنى الاشخاص في العالم
علما ان ترتيبه كان الثالث قبل صدور تقرير
هندنبرغ وتمثل الخسائر انتكاسه حاده
لجوتام اداني الذي هجر التعليم وتحول الى
ملياردير مع زياده قيمه اسهم مجموعته التي
تتضمن شركات موانئ ومطارات وتعديدا وطاقه
محمد زهير العربيه